[Music]
sure
[Applause]
good afternoon it feels like afternoon
because it's very bright here even
though it's like 6 p.m it's winter back
home so at this point it's probably
sunset um is there any chance we could
just get the slides for now
um
sorry this talk is a bit you know
difficult
let's see if we can just get the slides
on for now i'm sure the technical team
will help me
in the meantime
um
i should probably start by introducing
myself
my name is insantala kimkosi
well done tasia for pronouncing my names
that was incredible
and
i wear a lot of hats
but
the main hat that has brought me here
today is the fact that i am a software
engineer
i'm from the beautiful city of
johannesburg in south africa
[Applause]
and in south africa i work for an
organization or company called bbd
the full name is baron bajan dominic we
sound like a law firm but it's a 30 year
old 38 year old bespoke software firm
from south africa we build all sorts of
software for banks and the likes
my job is slightly different from
everyone else at bbd i work in a team
called atc
we are responsible for the company's
research and development functions
develop functions
but i think
well specialized consulting
the most fulfilling part of our job is
that we're also responsible for
providing training to pbd's 1000 odd
employees across the world and we also
are responsible for finding new talent
across the country
so
because i love javascript so much i'm
also the co-organizer of a monthly
meetup called josie.js if you ever find
yourself in south africa hit us up and
give us a cool talk and to try and
expand
access to javascript and this incredible
tool that we love we've also started
something called soetojs to take
javascript into the townships of south
africa as a start
the most important thing for you to know
however is that my twitter handle is at
enlarky underscore gaussian please feel
free to tweet me and let me know what
you think of this talk
so
this talk is going to be slightly
different from the rest of the talks
that you will have had today i mean we
started off by talking about a proposal
for typed javascript how incredible is
that
and we had some really really
informative talks this is not one of
them
in this talk i'm mostly going to be
telling you about myself
a lot of the bad decisions that i've
made
and a series of unfortunate events that
have led to this moment right here
i'll start off with a story like most
good stories it started off with me on
my way home from a work function after a
couple of beers
i
accidentally ended up on a very cheap
online shopping website called
wish
and
from the last i'm guessing most of you
know the site
and
i seem to have bought a drone
so
south africa is very far from everything
else this drone took about four months
to arrive and when it arrived i was like
who bought me a drone i mean
this is such a nice gift
i had no idea what was going on until i
checked my order history's like oh
i guess i
bought myself a drone
the drone was called the sg900s really
really cool drones got a couple of
features
we'll get back to the drone in a second
i'm going to tell you a bit more about
myself a couple of years ago i was
diagnosed with something called
narcolepsy
narcolepsy is a sleep disorder that's
characterized by excessive sleepiness
excessive sudden sleepiness
which means that i could fall asleep
right now don't worry it won't happen i
am on medication
and
also has a few scary things like sleep
paralysis and all sorts of these things
easily treatable so it's not really a
big problem around the same time i was
also diagnosed with attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder
no it's a mouthful right that's why we
just say adhd
and
what this combination means is that in a
sitting like this one
where you have to sit down and listen to
someone talk or in a lecture hall i'm
usually in one of two states a i'm
either trying to stay up and i'm
struggling because
wow it's a lot of information to take in
or b
the speaker will say something that
grabs my attention and now i
can't remember anything else that they
said because my mind just drifted away
i'm sure there are quite a few people
here that can resonate with that
and so when i attended a talk by a
colleague of mine gargana yang
she put up the slide
on her talk where she said i flew my
drone with not js she had gotten a drone
for her birthday and she says i crashed
my drone with node.js
now
jerry said a lot of very informative
things during that talk
which i cannot recall at all
that is because at that point i thought
whoa
jerry crashed the drone by flying it
with node then i thought hold on
if jerry could crash it
by flying her drone with node i wonder
how else i could crash a perfectly good
drone
and so today i bring you five ways to
kill a perfectly good drone
cool
let's get back to the drone
this drone
i got it and i had absolutely no use for
it i live in the city and it's illegal
to fly a drone within i think 50
kilometers of a police station a
national key point a school which means
that i can't fly the drone
so i decided i'm going to hack it and
fly with javascript now as any expert
hacker will tell you and i'm not one of
them the first step to hacking is
observation
you need to be able to see
how this tool is working observe it and
only after that can you try to actually
do your hacking
now i noticed that this drone was
being controlled either by an rc
controller or by an android app so i
figured
i'm a software developer an app is just
code if i can see what this app is doing
i can probably be able to mimic it
and try and write something that will do
the exact same thing
so i walked around the office and i said
i'd like to see what this app is sending
to the drone
people thought i had far too much time
instead of being billable i'm busy
asking these dumb questions and then
someone in it
indulged me they pointed me to this
thing called wireshark apparently with
wireshark i can sort of like log all of
the network activity at a port that i
pointed to and i was able to do that
although what happened is with the app
as soon as i started
or rather wireshark was pointed at the
drone and i wasn't really able to see
what the app was sending rather i was
seeing what the drone was receiving
and there seemed to be some sort of
break there that i didn't really
understand
someone else recommended that i use
apple devices because they apparently so
closely synced and linked to each other
that it would be easy to log the stuff
that time i didn't even use an iphone
and so i convinced a friend of mine
his name is matthew to let me log all of
his uh network traffic
for a day needless to say i saw some
interesting things on my friend's phone
but at this point i realized that i've
gone down this very deep rabbit hole and
i wasn't seeing an end to it so i
decided
um i should probably do something
slightly smarter and of course at this
point i knew that i would want to show
this to people and because i care about
your safety
right especially the people sitting on
beanbags decided to do something just
slightly smarter and
simply purchase a better drone
and easier drone to work with the drone
i bought is called the parrot mambo mini
apparently they've discontinued this i
found this out at 2 a.m this morning
after crashing my drone in my hotel room
but this drone
is called the parrot mumbo mini it's a
really super cool drone quite small fits
in the palm of my hand i think i've got
it over here and it comes with some
interesting accessories like
a pellet shooter
to i don't know shoot at my audience
it's got claws which means that i can
send my drone to go and get me beer
that's the next talk that i'll probably
work on
this drone has two ways of communicating
you can either use wi-fi or bluetooth
now because i'd spend so much time
learning about wi-fi decided let's focus
on bluetooth a bit for this one and so
everything that you're seeing here will
be bluetooth based
now bluetooth or bluetooth low energy is
slightly different from traditional
bluetooth
now back in africa when bluetooth came
out
everyone had these things attached to
their faces
pretending to be in super serious
meetings all the time
for people around my age
we didn't care about piracy laws we were
sending each other songs from beyonce
and the likes between each other's
phones
bluetooth low energy is slightly
different from your traditional
bluetooth
and its differences can be characterized
into three main things the first is
power consumption
ble
can ble devices rather can work for
years on end without the need of
the batteries or the power supply being
changed this starts influencing the
applications of bluetooth low energy
devices is ideal for applications where
you want to send short messages over
short amount of time as opposed to
streaming like an hd video
or sending a song and images across
different devices
another really interesting thing is that
with ble devices you can connect up to i
think 20 devices as opposed to the hard
limit of seven with traditional
bluetooth now these numbers are impacted
by the manufacturers by the hardware and
of course the software that we actually
go and write
i promised to tell you about myself so i
come from a game development background
i studied game design
and in game design we have two tools of
choice something called unity 3d and the
unreal engine i was traumatized by c
plus so
unity is what i use it's my go-to tool i
hit everything with it
the first app i've ever built i built
with unity um the first website
i built was with unity
and exported to web it's incredible
right and
then i joined this team called atc and
it just feels like i've gone through
some sort of transformation
right and it feels as though i've
developed this new weapon
and acts if you will
and it's called javascript
this is my new weapon and i hit
absolutely everything with it
ask me to build anything
and javascript will be my tool of choice
that's not a very popular statement at
work
um when i say that most of the senior
engineers just look at me and judge me
um
but the person who actually helped me
develop this new skill his name is mike
fraser incredible incredible web
developer he's a gde as well he gave a
talk where he asked this very incredible
question he said what should the web do
and while we as developers can you know
pompously discuss uh we think the web
should do this our users already know
what they want the web to do
they wanted to do everything and i'm one
of them i hate apps
i hate having to install an app that i'm
only going to ever use once if you're a
restaurant and i only use your services
once every six months chances are you
don't need an app
and so yes
and
and so i love love love working on the
browser and showing just how capable the
browser is but for us to be able to
create the same interesting experiences
delivered by native apps the browser
manufacturers also have to come to the
form and i think it's safe to say that
in recent years they have been actually
doing this
enough warming you up
i think it's time to actually get to the
demos
people in front i
hope you're ready
cool
i'm guessing they didn't tell you about
the helmet requirement cool
i think
we can all be in danger
so at number five obviously of ways to
kill a perfectly good drone we've got
javascript
now the first incarnation of this talk
was using node
to try and do what jerry did
and i had to uninstall drivers install
drivers and it worked on one machine and
didn't work on many other machines it
was just chaotic
and i asked the question how on earth
would i distribute the solution to other
people and so i decided to look at a
browser solution instead
that's the real reason why i changed not
because i couldn't get it working
seamlessly the browser is really really
powerful lately and the one thing that i
really like about the browser is web
bluetooth it allows the browser to
really start interacting with things
around us and you will see how
my favorite thing about the browser is
that we use javascript to
to build things in the browser
and the best thing about javascript is
not that it doesn't have types or that
it doesn't care that you write code
however you want to
my favorite thing about javascript is
the community
we have such a rich
community such a rich open source
community and the stats that we saw this
morning from the talk about the use of
javascript and typescript really
resonates with me and so i did what
every single javascript developer does
i looked for a script called drone.js
interestingly enough
i found this guitar brief pope
by peter o'chinessy and he had this one
script in his entire repo called drone
view 1.2.js i was like this is it
[Laughter]
it used red bluetooth
as a base and
i took that script and built onto it and
from that i managed to create two
scripts one called drone connection
management.js and another one called
road control the one just facilitates
all the complexities of dealing with web
bluetooth and the other one just exposes
an interface for me to be able to send
commands to the drone like hey drone
move left
right and then the drone goes sure i'll
do that
what this allows me to do is to write
code that looks like this to simply say
drone move left move right
maybe try and do a backflip and let's
see what happens
but i mean just from judging from the
switch statement
this is a pretty sure way of killing
your drone right
i'm not gonna show you a demo for this
because this forms the basis of
everything else that you're going to see
today so i'll move on to number four of
ways to kill a perfectly good drone
try and get your drone to mimic other
devices
so
i am absolutely passionate about human
computer interactions
it feels like we've been stuck with the
mouse and the keyboard for such a long
time that the way we think about
solutions is also limited to to just
that scope
i saw this morning when i looked at the
program again that during the party
we'll be playing something called joust
[Music]
absolutely love joust right and just
proves the point of just how incredible
the experiences can be when we take away
the mouse and the keyboard and we
introduce something interesting and so i
absolutely love exploring how humans can
interact with different computers
and
one way that the browser can do it is
through its web apis that get shipped
with most browsers nowadays
when i started working on this talk the
my favorite api is called the census api
it was still under the experimental flag
on chrome i think it's been standardized
now i'm not too sure i'll just have to
double check that but the sensors api
gives you access to the proximity sensor
to sensors such as the gyroscope and the
ambient light sensor on your devices
if your device is an accelerometer and
this computer that i got a week ago
seems to also have one i discovered this
morning as i was testing and
as well as your cell phones this means
that from your cell phone we can now get
access to the data in your accelerometer
and build interesting experiences out of
that
what this means for us is that we can
simply instantiate a new sensor just
like this maybe that should be a const i
don't think i'm going to reassign that
sensor but anyway
sensors now a new
accelerometer and to start reading this
data we simply just ask the sensor to
start
you can't read data forever you have to
stop at some point so we need a way to
also stop that and then of course we've
got
copic function that we can pass to this
event handler to try and
do something with this data
what this means is that we can then get
our drone to move based on the position
of our phones or tablets so anything
that has an accelerometer
anyway so these values are given to you
in xyz coordinates
and as you move it around
you get the different xyz values now i
went through a very scientific process
of mapping these xyz values to movement
of the drones by simply console logging
what all these values are when the phone
is in the different positions
and then
simply telling the drone if x is between
here and y is between here
do this what this ends up looking like
is this so as i lift my phone up the
drone can then take off
when i lean it forward the drone moves
forward backwards the drone moves
backwards and when i put it down the
drone tries to land
as you can see that's a perfectly good
way to kill a
working drone
i'm going to move on to the next one
try and fly the drone without hands
i'm a big marvel fan tony stark blows my
mind
and watching him in times with jarvis
without even touching anything has
always been something i've wanted to
recreate so when i started this i
immediately knew that this is something
i want to explore
and so i found this thing it's called
the leap motion sensor right it's aimed
at game developers um i wonder how i
found out about it but what this thing
does is that it maps your hands in the
digital space and all of the joins in
your hands it can identify different
hands and it allows you to interact with
with
items in the digital space based on the
movement and positioning of your hands
again it gives us these values in x y z
coordinates and using that
i went through the very scientific
process of console logging those values
in order to fly the drone again
[Applause]
and so
maybe i should show you this in
in a demo let me see if i've got stuff
running uh i'm we just need screen share
nothing else
sorry team
and i should probably move this
over
don't do live demos it's a trap
cool
let's look at
very beautiful website you can see that
i'm a
full stack developer
so
what we have here is a very simple
html page built with no framework at all
and we have a script here that magic
drone connection management script that
i wrote what allows me to do is that
once the drone is on you can i hope you
can see it blinking
i guess i can do that i've got green
lights blinking means that it's ready to
pay and if i then click connect to drone
it should appear there so it exposes a a
a bluetooth id that i can then
connect to based on the characteristics
of the drone
once i've paired the drone i can
take off oh it didn't pay one second
what do you do if it doesn't work you
just reload the page right
and we're waiting for it it's still in
pairing mode
[Laughter]
i didn't leave those console logs in i
might just have to restart
the strone
let's
reload that
do you guys remember that first slide
that i started with when i said it's
time for a demo
what could possibly go wrong
and now it's doing something i've never
seen in my life
if someone has a bluetooth device on
please stop using it i pick
cool let's try that again cool the demo
or the drone is freshly restarted we've
reloaded our page click connect to drone
will the drone
appear there we go
let's see if it pairs
oh the drone is actually too far from me
um so i'm gonna
put it here instead let's see if it then
connects
let's try that again
no
my goodness
what is happening
let's try that one more time
if it now crashes in my face it's fine
it's worth it
let me put that there
power on
it's okay i've got backup videos so if
if all else fails i will prove to you
that it once worked
i'll blame it on bing in europe it's
fine
cool let's see we can connect to it
and it still does not want to connect
cool i'm going to move on and i'll show
you guys a video of this instead
in a second
but i want to talk to you about
something else first
just need to
remove this battery
that is the most software dev thing i've
done in this entire talk
should you try it one more time
[Applause]
if it works now it's because the screen
wasn't full screen
we know who to blame for that
and it just disconnected again let's
just try that one more time
i'm scared of taking this off from my
hands because it will hurt me
so ted just now do you see why i need to
retire this talk
just try if you have a bluetooth device
on
please switch it off
cool let's try this one last time and
then i'm going to move on and show you
the videos instead
let's try that again
connect to the drone
it needs to be on first
that's generally how electronics work
there we go
connect
there it is
it's not paid i hope
i'm gonna click take off just to check
but the light should be solid green it's
cool i'm gonna move on from that one
cool and show you the video instead
let's move that there
just need a second
it's a great opportunity for one of the
sponsors to say if you want to see it
work come to our sponsorship booth
[Music]
what that's actually supposed to look
like is this
is that as i move my hands around this
thing you're supposed to
see it send all of this data to the
different parts of the drone now this
would allow me to do really interesting
movements as well such as rotational
movements so rotating to the right and
rotating to the left
which
creates more danger and a greater chance
of us actually crashing this incredible
drone
cool and that's
[Applause]
a that of me is still really hoping that
this thing comes back to life is
especially for the next part of this
talk
now
i promise to tell you about myself i
have a nine-year-old brother
and i think he inspires a lot of the
work that i do
one of the things that he makes me think
about is the future of technology and
the role that
my country in particular has to play in
it
it wouldn't be an important talk without
stats so i'm just going to put out some
stats there
just to you know check box
our unemployment rate is sitting at just
under 35
as of the first quarter of this year
now if you think this is bad
wait till you find out that almost 70
percent of our youth is unemployed and
our definition of youth is quite
generous
described as anyone between the ages of
15 and 30
that is not currently registered in an
institution of learning
did i press something yeah that is not
currently
in an institution of learning it also
includes people who
it only includes people who are actively
seeking employment so the people that
have given up that have not been able to
find any employment are not actually
included in that stat which means that
the real number is probably
significantly higher than that
what's confusing on the other hand is
that we also have a critical skills
shortage in the country
there's an estimated 70 000 jobs that we
can't seem to fill in the ict sector
alone
now this means that we need to find
interesting and innovative ways to get
people into tech
we kept talking about language and
communication throughout this conference
today and i think one of the interesting
things i found is that as technologists
we often get stuck in the detail of what
it is that we're doing even when we talk
about people even when we talk to other
people that are not actually technical
i still don't understand blockchain
because every single time i've had
blockchain enthusiasts explain it to me
it's always like ah
decentralized
take over the banks
right and i think we need to find a way
to make technology relatable especially
in the context of a country like mine
where most people or a big portion of
our population doesn't have access to
computers until they get to universities
and so
one of the ways that i've found that are
quite interesting is to
fly drones
with bananas
now i'm going to try this one more time
and hope that it works
right
so
i've got a couple of bananas here
they're real i promise
i checked
just this morning
and so
i'm gonna put up my web page again my
very interesting
website
yep
it's perfect it's fine i'll just use
this cool let's go to fruits
the button is green here that says
connect to drone so maybe it'll be
different
cool so what i have here in front of me
and i think the camera will show you in
a second is that i've got a couple of
fruits that i bought from
a store here so if it doesn't work we
blame it on the hungarian bananas
[Laughter]
and
what we can do is that we can just plug
in i mean this is very scientific stuff
right
and you can see that all i need to do is
very scientifically just plug in
these bananas
and using this i can now build very
interesting ways of interacting with
this drone i'm going to try it one more
time i'm going to keep it close
and risk the danger of
it crashing in my face
that would definitely make a memorable
talk and we see it there again
we pay
and it is still refusing to pay for some
odd reason let's try that one more time
there's one thing i didn't try actually
can i right click
ctrl f5
no
there we go
cool now i can right click yes
hard reload there we go
cool
let's try that
let's pile it up again
it's okay i've got a video for this as
well so you're fine
cool
so there's our drone again
it's ready to pair i'm just gonna reload
that
just for luck
it's looking for the drone
found it
let's see if putting it down
helps at all
and you're gonna click pair
still no but it's cool
i
think for this one we've got some
we've got a button there or this block
that tells us what's supposed to be
happening with the drone right and
what's happening here is that this is
plugged in yes it is
is that by me touching the different
drones
move some
plastic
by me touching the different controllers
i can then start sending
commands to the drone should probably
close my devtools mode
see
so
there
did i connect the correct things man
what on earth is going on
not even this is working out geez
hold on
uh i can't do that can i
then i'm gonna disconnect from the
screen
let's just do this instead
i nearly said something that i don't
think i'm allowed to say on stage
about the device that i'm using
there we go cool so it's a usb problem
cool
and so
now what we can do is that we can start
seeing that i can send the different
commands to the drone based on what i'm
doing right and now we can even start
doing interesting things like
trying to flip the drone
there we go right so that's supposed to
flip the drone
should i try to connect now
funny thing is that i tested this just
this morning and it worked in my room
that is the best thing i've ever heard
see
the pairing
maybe
let's try reset it one last time
the drone is just choosing not to pay
which is not the problem i had earlier
and this is why this talk is now retired
need to switch it on
one more time
there we go
let's try that again
connect
searching
there we go
yeah it is
sorry say that
again that is not a bad idea so what
we're going to do is that i'm going to
restart this
server locally
what's funny is that i had
a talk um my vs code is frozen for some
reason
[Laughter]
let's see let's try that one last time
and
there you go
it's murphy's law right everything that
can go wrong
will go wrong
this is it this is it
final try final attempt
what's horrible is that i am
as soon as i finish this talk i'm gonna
go back and try and figure out what's
happening and then it's just gonna work
immediately
murphy's low indeed
so
one last attempt and then i'm letting
this go and showing you guys the video
cool let's try that one more time
drone is available for pairing
still says pit
[Music]
[Applause]
would you like to see it flip
there we go
i forgot to program a landing button
[Applause]
let's try a safe land
cool
[Applause]
hey
i've already gone over time
and so as much as i would love to show
you that other
demo from before
i'll show you after the closing of this
conference for today but
the number one
way of making sure that you kill your
drone that i wanted to show you
but unfortunately can't
because the internet isn't too great in
here is to fly it
with people
someone said oh crap right you're in
front right and this is definitely a
guaranteed way of killing your drone now
the idea here was to
let you
tweet commands to the stroke
right and how it's supposed to work is
that you're supposed to tweet with the
hashtag
jsconfp
and send commands to the drone don't
reach for your phones please
i think my server's running and it might
just
[Laughter]
so please do not tweet
and
how it's supposed to work is that every
five seconds or three seconds it would
get a random tweet with the hashtag put
your phone down oh okay cool
it would get one random tweet and pick
out all of these different words the
next incarnation of this demo is
supposed to use some sentiment analysis
and only pick up nice complimenting
tweets
so if you say nice things about my talk
then your commands would be sent here
before i close off i want to give you a
bonus one
the most guaranteed way it seems to
crash a perfectly good working drone is
to travel 15 000 kilometers across the
world to a conference
very short story last night we had the
speaker's dinner and a lot of the
speakers that i said to us kept making
me anxious about the fact that i had no
recordings of my demo they're like but
what if the drone doesn't work have you
tested it since you arrived right
just today they were telling me what if
your laptop explodes right
so i was so nervous i got to my room
last night i pulled out the drone and i
tried to fly it to see if it works i
turned it on it took off and crashed
into the door immediately
i tried it again it did the exact same
thing again so i put it away went to bed
woke up early this morning took the
entire thing apart put it back together
and i think it did a pretty decent job
barring the bluetooth connection issues
the number one question i always get
when i talk about this drone is why why
on earth do you do this
and and why does your company even let
you waste time doing the stuff
i think as developers
we are in those unique fields where you
can never really stop learning
so much changes in our ecosystem and
it's so difficult to keep up with
everything
the rate at which we get these changes
is absolutely gobsmacking and it's very
difficult to keep up
this is a problem that i see across our
business i have very senior and
experienced engineers coming to me and
saying i've been writing c-sharp for the
past 20 years or what on earth is this
javascript thing and how do i go about
learning it
as someone in my role i need to try and
keep up to date with what's happening
and one of the ways i do that is by
building useless things
absolutely love it learning doesn't have
to be boring learning can be fun
you determine what that fun is for me
it's building useless things like flying
drones with bananas but for you it could
be something else like building iot
devices from your home with your partner
so
for me
this is a way that i use to communicate
to other people that aren't necessarily
tech savvy the peers even those that are
tech savvy like bananas and this is a
way that i make sure that i keep
learning that that i keep learning and
growing so the one thing that i'd like
you to take away from this talk
is
two things one don't do life demos
two
keep playing
friends all binary and non-binary my
name is lakin gossi thank you very much
uh